for some reason they believe that by
making it illegal to have sex with
someone when you're HIV positive and not
tell them would cause let's say you had
sex with five guys and then you go whoa
here hey I lost a weekend just a weekend
okay I can go with it
and I'm glad to bring on this next guest
let me set the stage here a little bit
you can find him at reasonably gay.com I
found him in my timeline he's been
following for a while and I noticed this
vitriolic hatred that was coming for
this guy from the gay community
specifically because he was talking
about HIV and AIDS in the gay community
and non-disclosure laws and sort of the
statistics anyways not things that are
politically correct to do
turns out the gentleman coming on the
show is gay and well on Schad okay come
on now you don't have the the full age
you just is it just the Hibbs just the
his I have a $4,000 a month medication
that prevents the AIDS gosh how do you
know is that is that covered by a bottle
I don't but Noah the Ryan White program
pays for the most of it okay so you were
getting a lot of flack from the gay
community on this on Twitter I threw
something else out Jared you can bring
it up here throughout the CDC stats and
I got a lot of flock because I at Cal
Poly I made some aids jokes
very funny jokes the edge jokes that I
made and people were kind of mad at me
but then they turned on you why is the
gay community so furious with someone
like you when I mean it's no secret that
you're gay and in the hip because I'm
for some reason the gay community both
LGBT years they are focused more on this
idea of stigma like it's still 1992 and
we think you can get age from handshake
there their foot they're obsessed with
Isis idea on national or worldwide AIDS
to AIDS day all they kept talking about
was we must fight the stigma I I've been
hiv-positive for eight years I have
never experienced anything negative by
anyone that people are a sneeze and
people you know call nine-one-one like
they're worried about me but no one ever
no one's ever treated me badly does it
gaping right well exactly except of the
game now forgive me you could tell me if
I'm too personal now you did you so
eight years was it transmitted because
of another
another homosexual gentleman yeah
sexually assaulted and the individual
was intentionally trying to infect me
really yeah well you said nonchalantly
like is that is that a common thing kind
of like a like a tag you're aids yes is
and and and there's a whole group of gay
men
they're called bugchasers and they
intentionally seek out hiv-positive
people trying to the gay men trying to
get HIV can you substantiate this
because it sounds a little outlandish
for just my hetero
it's a it's totally an entire episode of
of queers folk was about the bugchasers
they they were mantis eyes it's it's
well I think bugchasers I would think
usually it's someone chasing the bug
like storm [ __ ] you know I'm thinking
like twister someone be like let's go
into it but it's the opposite it's the
people with it try no now what okay what
do they get out of that what do they get
out of transmitting I don't understand
it
I don't either they're they're people
that are and there's actually the reason
why the disclosure laws were created is
because there are people that want to
harm other people once they become HIV
positive they intentionally go out and
try to infect other people just because
they're sociopaths they just stop and
there's no explain well let me ask you
this disclosure laws seems pretty
reasonable why and this is me being
ignorant why would anyone in their right
mind gay or straight opposed disclosure
laws for people having sex if they have
AIDS or HIV well the the view of the
presidential Advisory Council on
hiv/aids and the US Department of
Justice Civil Rights Division as
organized by Zack Ford who's the LGBT
elder for Think Progress
oh yeah okay he's he's mine he's my
favorite on who needs me okay
but yeah so uh there the view is that
they call it criminalizing HIV they
believe that it dissented did it D
incentivizes individuals from getting
tested for HIV because
they fear prosecution if they know their
status is positive as a result the
stigma against people with HIV increases
and fewer people seek care for HIV which
would increase the potential for
transmitting the virus for some reason
they believe that by making it illegal
to have sex with someone when you're HIV
positive and not tell them would cause
let's say you had sex with five guys and
then you go hey weekend just a weekend
okay I can go with it you know it's a
slow weekend okay so asking around you
know it's a slowly ask Matt gay Darren
allegedly going and then you go and get
tested like we're all supposed to do
right by sweetly and you get tested you
find out you're positive now you're
afraid that you go that if you tell your
partners hey I'm positive we should get
tested they'll call the police you don't
go to jail that's what that's the idea
that they're going around obviously this
how it works well I do think if you are
positive and you have sex knowing you're
positive and don't disclose it I think
you should go to jail I agree so why is
that on why is that scene is
unreasonable because it's it falls back
to stigma it's this idea of
criminalizing HIV it's the idea that
what is it's borderline attempted murder
if you have it and you have sex with
someone and you don't tell them I mean
it could be manslaughter cuz maybe they
maybe they're not as responsible with
their testing uh-huh III don't I feels
like I'm missing something so this is
why gay people were so mad at you just
because I mean you're you're gay you do
you do the gates I mean okay let me
think about let me give stretch let me
give you a hypothetical we'll bring you
back up to the break but you know okay
it's a night it's a good night you're
out you're at the bar it's ladies night
or whatever you guys drink your gay
drinks and you having a good time you're
cosmos while TVs are faint a Pilates or
daiquiris it's fine listen we can hang
out and something happens and you take
it back to the apartment
all you want is for someone to have to
say by the way I have the hives and the
gay LGBT community is mad at you for
that position yes they think that's
discrimination it's unfair stigmatizing
HIV and they believe that because HIV
medications
to an undetectable state where it's
considered impossible to spread is it
impossible
it's it's it's almost impossible from
their perspective I don't I don't risk
it but is it impossible not near
impossible they refer to it as almost
impossible okay nearly impossible very
unlikely that's what the thing because
they can't detect how many virus you
have in your body but that requires that
you take the medications on a regular
basis you miss it for 24 to 48 hours the
virus can adapt
you have no idea well I get our blood
tested every three months oh my gosh
okay I'm fascinated I want to keep you
on shed if you can we have another
segment sorry that I miss Katie you know
Chad and not with the AIDS just the his
well yet we will bring him back please
gay though super gay loud always
laughter with Crowder stay tuned we'll
talk more aids in gay stuff we are
dancing the happy songs bringing back my
guest you can follow him on the Twitter
Chad Felix G or you know reasonably
gay.com Chad thanks for staying with us
so we were talking about during the
break we kept talking about the
unreasonable hatred you've gotten so let
me take it a step further because I know
you're gay and you're talking about the
disclosure laws people talk about stigma
with the gay community and eight
distinct I mean being honest as far as I
have the CDC stats is it fair to say
that the United States of America today
if you have AIDS
the overwhelming statistical chance is
your gay yes alright now so it wouldn't
be hate speech to say AIDS is the gay no
and the and the LGBT community only
references HIV stigma with gay people
they don't talk about women or drug
users they talk exclusively about gay
people and all the services all of the
funding all of the stigma talk is always
about it's not about people in Africa
it's always about gay people not all the
all of the the only people who have ever
been affected by the disclosure laws are
gay men and then there's been a couple
straight men who have been accused of
trans men 802
but the people that they focus on all
these articles all the rage is about
that this is hurting gay men it's a way
to criminalize homosexuality so on the
one side hiv/aids is exclusively a gay
issue until they imagined that it might
be viewed negatively and then suddenly
it's back to the 1990s everyone can get
it right well yeah I have the CDC stats
up here and you know a lot of people
will even argue that see see stats are
being generous in non gay related age
transmissions because they're sometimes
there including bisexuals among
heterosexual cuz I have 92% of male to
male sexual content and then another two
point one percent so basically 95
percent would be male to male sexual
contact and then there's some drug use
very little heterosexual contact its how
how is it helpful to lie about
statistics that that's my issue because
it's clearly a problem and people like
you speak out against it and they get so
upset with you the social justice where
your gay people the vitriolic hatred how
is it helpful like you said to flip flop
and say it's not a gay person's disease
and then while you're trying to
criminalize gayness alright I'll be
honest I you know how pro-choicers
always accused pro-lifers of only caring
about the fetus until birth yeah it
seems like the game Kennedy only cares
about HIV until you get it and then your
statistic and you move forward there's a
drug I take it's called Truvada that if
someone who is not hiv-positive takes it
it can significantly limit your ability
to actually get it the virus won't
convert as easily you can only get
Truvada if you're HIV positive I mean
it's the they don't consider any actual
ramifications of what they're doing
they're only thinking about feelings
right they're worried about how the HIV
positive person feels being asked are
you HIV positive it's up to you as a
person having sex with someone to
protect yourself you know I allowed to
ask are you HIV positive you're not
supposed to tell you're the one who's
supposed to take the Truvada you're the
one who's supposed to wear the condom
you're the one
supposed to protect yourself entirely
it's it's the opposite of a culture
right well well except some of the times
I mean you know if it's like kind of
surprise AIDS as you said when they're
not disclosing it yeah I mean that to me
is borderline attempted murder if
someone is doing it knowing in and not
disclosing it I again if it sounds like
I'm ignorant i I've looked at the
reasons that you've presented from the
other side I've not found anything even
remotely reasonable to oppose disclosure
laws with aids I'll make some eggs jokes
well go ahead okay
does it pause magazine which is which
whenever you become HIV positive do they
give you a welcome package and HIV
you've got a resort yeah it's it's a
club yeah buzz magazine is the is the
default magazine that's supposed to be
inspiring and they have a whole section
on HIV is not a crime with stories of
these poor men who were put in jail
because all they did was not disclose
and then someone called the police and
how unfair it is and how difficult it
was for them they're more worried that
gay men might be inconvenienced and
their access to sex is really that
person if you if you have HIV or AIDS
and you don't disclose jail seems like
the appropriate place I can't think of
any place more appropriate am I out of
line now I completely agree with you and
it's it's frustrating because they're
putting it in terms of it will put that
if we make it illegal to transmit HIV
knowingly that it will reduce people's
willingness to go get effective
antiviral treatment cuz they won't get
tested in the first place they're trying
to make it sound as though disclosure
laws increase HIV what sound too--not
they're trying to accommodate the worst
in the gay community because if you're
the kind of person who wants to not have
to disclose so you won't get tested
because you don't really know you're
just a horrible person then you probably
should be locked up let's pull the
Benghazi guy who made the movie Trump up
some charges and put them in jail
regardless if they don't want to
acknowledge that they have AIDS
let me ask you this though because I
know people will say this watching this
video I can see the comments section or
people is an interesting
is this mainstream in the gay community
them funny against disclosure laws or
just some small contingency of people
who are who are vocal like is there any
actual influence is this is this an
actual argument at the table oh yeah I
mean the the presidential Advisory
Council on hiv/aids aids.gov
pause magazine all you know think
progress they type the LGBT section they
all wind up on that side yeah hmm
aids.gov describes you know should
sharing your HIV status guidelines it
says for each person you want to tell
ask yourself if the person needs to know
now or if it's better to wait you know
it's it's all about why don't you ask
the person you're about to infect with
AIDS right what us it's funny I had a
bit about this and wrote a similarly
pissed bill they got mad had a bit about
AIDS and a couple of jokes about AIDS
and one of them that was talking about
the movie rent I'm sure well you're gay
you've probably seen rent and I was
talking about rent and it was like you
know we don't need to change society
needs to change no no you you you need
to change you have eight society doesn't
have AIDS like no it's not your fault
literally this is a film every single
one of you all of your friends have AIDS
do you have any idea how incredibly rare
that is you're all having sex with each
other in the west or east village and
shooting here on with dirty needles if
you make it past noon without AIDS
you're on you're in the bonus round as
far as I'm considered and the black
lives matter kids are at the back and
they're marking us even crowd I made
aids jokes I do find it funny that's put
there as this beautiful story or so I
feel like anyone who's reasonable
watching going like all of you have AIDS
this is this is your fault and that that
seems to be the mindset and you're
saying this is mainstream it is and my
reality my view is that I have a unique
virus it's adapted to my body no one in
the entire world can access this virus
if I don't let it happen unless I'm in
some like giant look like the car crash
and everyone bathes in my blood it
outside of that there's no way for my
virus to escape my body the virus will
die with me if every person who had HIV
did that
would be going on a generation this
doesn't like cancer it doesn't just
happen in people it's not transmittable
through just touching or sneezing there
are specific acts that you have to take
yeah and it's careful running at these
feet and I know how specific those acts
are and it's not even just the
traditional vanilla getting busy no I
mean it's it's very simple to stop
hiv/aids we don't need more funding we
we've had decades of education and
awareness straight people are nice to us
we're not discriminated by medical staff
or not discriminated at work we have
federal laws protecting us it's our
responsibility right now to make sure
our virus doesn't leave our body and for
some reason that's too much to ask
couldn't it just be wiped out with the
gay community within a generation if
they did what you're advocating wouldn't
it basically yeah yeah absolutely
if because gay gay men are the majority
if we all just said if we all stop being
selfish and just being responsible I'm
not gonna let my virus leave my body it
would be gone when we all died yeah this
the speckling of street people that have
it through drugs wouldn't impact it
enough of an outbreak yeah and you're
right well in your virus would go with
you'd be like not what be just not
without my virus think of it as Sally
Fields daughter okay let me ask you this
does this translate to the you know the
blood transfusion the giving blood a lot
of people that's an issue does the gay
community not want people to have to
disclose when giving blood if it's
undetectable viral loads I've heard that
as well yes but I might need blood
someone's gonna run me over with their
car eventually Chad what can I do about
this yeah that's that's a legitimate
problem we already want through the
stigma nonsense about gay men donating
blood and then undetectable means that
the reason that I'm undetectable but I'm
not cured of HIV is because HIV still is
in my body but they can't measure it
with current medical technology right if
I donate blood and they test that blood
it's gonna come up HIV negative there's
they can't verify it but doesn't mean
HIV isn't in especially what's going to
someone with an odd or autoimmune
condition or a compromised immune system
there is a greater chance of it being
potentially damaging
but but we don't want it we don't want
the HIV positive gay person do you feel
discriminated against when they decide
they want to go do anything well you've
been the lifeblood of this conversation
but I don't want your blood and my
morphine drip if that's what happens so
let me let's leave with this in your
perfect world in engage had perfect
world what how would this be handled how
would not only legislatively but how
should gay people come out and approach
this issue look slightly we should have
very strict laws about transmission that
this is this is neglect it is it's the
same as exposing someone to dangerous
chemicals you have to be in control of
it and socially we don't need to shame
people for getting HIV but we do need to
shame people for letting it be playing
it's spread we don't need to focus on
this idea that you are responsible for
making sure your HIV doesn't spread and
they're unwilling to do that right now
but in my perfect world that's what we
would be doing we would be internally
looking at the gay community and saying
gay men look at our lifestyles look at
what you're doing you can still have fun
you can still go to bathhouses and do
drugs and all if you want to but make
this a top priority in your life that
you're not gonna let other people get
exposed that's perfectly reasonable me I
don't know why that's offensive well I
know it's I mean it's offensive to
people if you don't disclose that the
cows were treated with hormones on milk
for some reason when it comes to the
topic of HIV however we want it blind I
all right well listen seems to me that
BPA and plastic isn't quite as upsetting
as AIDS in my bath house but this is
just me people can tweet me at s Crowder
people can find you at reasonably
gay.com right Chad that's right
reasonably good thank you something you
know only to bring you back and and and
be reasonable again and let me a little
final question is this like mandatory as
a gay man that mustache you just have to
do it yes I I can't I'm I'm a ginger so
I can't grow right here I can't do that
awesome handlebar things this is
this is as much manly as I get that's
like that's like the the homo pass of a
hood pass yeah you have the most - all
right
and it's funny because it's darker right
here so if the lights bad I well
that's problematic high exposure
well you know what listen you look good
here you got that flowing red hair um
seems like seems like the the hives have
been good to you Chad we must let you go
thank you so much for being on louder
with Crowder that was Chad Felix
green reasonably gay.com see that's the
kind of thing that you don't find on
other shows that is sure very comparable
gonna know - because you could eat blood
you could eat you could be run over i
bug you I've seen you kind of itch on
the steering wheel well I can only
imagine if you get run over early by
somebody named either Farouk or maybe
Janet Janet's a total witch with a
capital B lotto with Crowder we'll wrap
this up with a nice bow after this don't
get AIDS like this video subscribe by
clicking my ho my god you're hideous I
mean really you are just an awful
looking human being believe me I know
I'm no prize either okay but if I'm like
a 5 out of 10 you are scraping by it - I
you know what you could subscribe it
might partially redeem you you know what
here subscribe click my face the button
above you can watch one of these video
but if you subscribe I will personally
upload some beauty tips just for you but
don't don't turn your face like that ah